I wish there was just more compassion.
No,
we don't want to make something difficult.
We just want to be acknowledged.
My daughter was a victim
and she's being punished.
Okay.
Hi,
my name is Marissa gold. I am
a parent. I have two girls,
10 and 13 and I'm also a parenting
expert with my own parenting company,
intuit parenting.
My Name is David Epstein and I'm a
pediatric intensive care physician.
I'm Gary Schlepper.
I'm an internal medicine physician.
I'm Bob Sears.
I'm a pediatrician.
I guess my greatest passion is
just to help encourage a full,
complete informed
consent for vaccinations.
Awesome. Marissa? By
trade, I'm a designer.
I am also an activist and a mother.
I'm Melissa Floyd and I would consider
myself an informed consent advocate.
I just want to make sure this conversation
can be open for people and continue
to inform people and to listen to everyone
to understand why we each come to our
opinion on this.
First statement is I am vaccinated,
so I actually wasn't fully vaccinated.
Interestingly,
I grew up with two parents that
were into alternative medicine,
so I was not vaccinated as a child,
but as I got older I vaccinated myself.
Well,
I was vaccinated as a child,
but in my last vaccine was about 15 years
ago when I returned to college and I
had a severe reaction in that
I became arthritic in my hands.
Went to many,
many doctors that nobody knew what was
going on and why it was happening and
just shrugged like it doesn't make sense.
You're too young to have arthritis.
And it wasn't until having kids and
sort of digging into my own research for
them that a lot of
answers started coming up.
And I think it's unfortunate
that a lot of it is overlooked
for me, it, I'll continue
to get vaccinated. We know
regardless of of the risks,
because I've seen too many
things on the other side.
I've seen kids come into the ICU and
die from being on getting the flu.
I've always felt like though,
the risks are far outweighed by
the benefits of, of getting the
protection,
not getting vaccinated and
dangerous other people.
Okay.
I will acknowledge of course as a
pediatrician, I know vaccines work.
I know they give you protection and they
vary greatly in what that protection is.
It's not like a hundred percent
magical shield over you completely,
but I do acknowledge there are some
vaccines like the measles vaccine and the
chicken pox vaccine, but honestly if
you don't get those vaccines, yeah,
you do risk the disease
and passing it to others.
It's such a complicated topic.
Vaccines and you're starting to get micro
with each individual vaccine and that
definitely the question was talking
about the big picture and I think yeah,
if you get micro,
probably some of these vaccines.
I think when you're giving kids
medication you have to get micro about it.
I don't think it's doing your kids any
service to just say vaccines are all made
the same and they're all safe and
healthy and good for you that everybody's
benefiting from it because that's false.
We studied them before we
released them to the public.
We study them so we do know they're safe.
That's the thing is we know ish.
What else?
He say,
being an intensivist,
I see the worst of the worst,
and so seeing the other side of
kids who don't get vaccinated,
I saw a kid walking with meningococcemia,
which I haven't seen in decades.
He had all four limbs cut off.
They had to be amputated
because it was all dead tissue.
You forget how bad things
were before we had vaccines.
I didn't step forward for that because
I don't like the assumption that if a
child is unvaccinated,
somehow they are of risk to everyone
and also knowing that vaccinated
individuals can also be
carrying and spreading diseases.
I think it's very polarizing to separate
the two as if if you're vaccinated,
you're totally fine.
You're not risking anybody anything.
Unvaccinated children don't just have
diseases and hanging out in their bodies
waiting to unload at any moment.
Anybody could be spreading diseases,
especially things like polio and pertussis
that are not completely covered by
the vaccine.
Okay.
I do anything to keep my child safe.
I agree. I don't have kids, but
when I think about it, you know,
the idea was vaccines is
you're protecting all of us.
You're protecting the group.
Okay.
Now there's this idea of herd immunity
and so I think that's why it's really
important to talk about because this is
an issue that doesn't just affect you.
It affects everyone around you because
there's people that aren't vaccinated
that are sick or have immune issues or
they're too young to get a vaccine and
they count on her to immunity.
I think
most people too,
like I started out vaccinating my
daughter because I believed all the same
things that you said.
It wasn't until she had a reaction and
several reactions that I actually had to
look at it differently where I,
I realized that by continuing
vaccinating for her,
that actually would hurt her and yet
everyone wants me to do it for the
population as if I'm supposed to continue
to sacrifice my child for everyone
else.
Well, I mean there, there are
medical exemptions for vaccines.
If your child has a reaction and
then there's, there's concern,
I think that's valid,
but I think a,
a larger population is using other
justifications to not get the vaccine.
You know, a number of families
who look into vaccines,
they will decide to opt out of vaccines
because they feel they are just not
willing to risk the side effects.
But side effects or the
side effects are like one in a million,
one in 2 million.
Whereas the side effects
from the diseases,
when I see all these outbreaks
and things like that,
I'm going to choose vaccines everyday.
And that's,
I think right there is the disservice to
this conversation because it is a risk
benefit analysis. And what's unfortunate
is how downplay those risks are.
I only started investigating vaccines
because I ended up with a kid with an auto
immune disorder. So what does that
mean? And instead of finding answers,
I have more questions. The
one in a million is not a
real number. It's really not.
And so the more that that is put out
and so people think that no, it's not.
Not when you're talking about
the different kinds of reactions,
well I think the number you're referring
to is Anna Filactic shock that Anna
Filactic shock is of course,
extremely rare.
Whereas when you look at seizures from
the MMR vaccine in our one in 3000 right.
But again is creating fear,
worry that you get the those on
your side kind of down play those.
So my daughter has seizures,
seizures for most people are considered
kind of a big deal. You know,
when it happens to you that
that downplayed element of,
while that's not Anna Filactic shock,
it's just a seizure. It is just a seizure.
But seizures can be dangerous.
I don't think it's an idea of downplay.
I think it comes back to what we were
saying with the risk benefit analysis.
And I think the data's very clear that
the benefits of giving vaccines by far
outweigh the risks. So I don't think
it's a question of downplaying the risks.
They're there,
but we also know that children were
dying and now they're not. And yes,
there's side effects,
but they're not as bad as
what we had before. Vaccines,
I don't always trust my doctor's opinion.
Anytime anyone, whether it's a teacher, a
friend, something I read online, my mom,
you know, my, the doctor, anytime
anyone tells me, oh you should do this.
Especially if it has to do
with their health, I'm going
to do research. And it's,
I would be careful about saying it's that
I don't trust my doctor, but that has,
that trust has been developed over time.
And so I would say in the early years
when my children were very young,
when they would say, this
is what we recommend, yes,
of course there were times where I got
a second opinion or did the research on
my own and ask the questions. And I
think that as parents we have to do that.
Well, it's hard to trust someone who sees
your child for 10 minutes, twice a year.
Uh, in the end, parents
know their children best.
And that little office visit where
your pediatrician looks at your child,
he does not know your child
the way you know your child.
So it's really hard for
whatever recommendation he's
making to be really based
in India,
individualized for your kid.
So if you were to come to
your doctor and say, Hey,
my child is acting differently after this,
this well visit appointment,
something's wrong.
You want them to trust that you have an
established relationship and listened to
you and hear you and understand that as
a mother just because you don't have the
Dr in front of your name, it doesn't
your opinion somehow less valuable.
Yeah,
I mean I think like anyone,
doctors are fallible and they don't
know everything and I think it's very
important,
like you were mentioning to have a really
strong doctor patient relationship.
I think that's really hard. And today's
10 minute appointment age, you know,
it makes it really difficult.
But like as a young doctor,
I think there's a lot of distrust when
it comes to physician recommendations.
It sucks because you know,
you spend decades training and learning
and your heart is in this place where
you want to like be of service to
people and then you're not trusted.
But you know,
to answer the question,
you shouldn't just blindly trust
anyone's opinion, your doctor or anyone.
Ironically, the doctors
are the ones that, well,
I trust my physicians.
Um,
my daughter has epilepsy and in March
she was also diagnosed with juvenile
idiopathic arthritis.
I went to the rheumatologist and the
rheumatologist is that we're going to put
her on methotrexate. And I looked
at her, I'm like, methotrexate,
that's a chemotherapy
chemotherapeutic agent that,
you know, kids with cancer get.
And she's like,
yes,
but we use it in a low dose and it
doesn't cause harmful side effects.
You have to trust me. I said, okay.
And I trusted her and I
am so glad that I did.
Before all this happened,
she was a competitive gymnast and she
used to walk up and down the stairs.
Like she was 90 years old.
She couldn't hold a pencil in her hand.
Now she's back on the bars back on the,
on the beam doing things,
which my wife and I
never thought that she would do again.
So yes. Do I trust my physicians? Yes.
Do I question them? Yes. I will say,
look, can we do this for her? Can we
do this instead? And yes. You know, I,
I can appreciate what you guys have
said as far as people hearing you.
And I think that's the biggest problem
in medicine is that time is short.
Clinicians aren't listening. And I think
that as, as a pediatrician, you know,
one of the most important jobs that
we have is to listen to parents.
And I think that if any
pediatrician isn't doing that,
they're not doing their job.
There is too much hostility
between the two sides.
I don't like it. I don't, I
want us to be able to talk.
I want us to be able to have
relevant and educated conversations.
And I think at the core of
this conversation is what
is at the core of humanity
and being a parent,
which is that we all want to do right by
our children and we want to lead happy,
healthy and productive lives.
Yeah.
I have no doubts in my mind of how
I've come to my decision making on the
subject, which has been tedious
and thorough to say the least.
I did not to go down this path in my life,
but I have people who
won't be friends with me,
who I've had death
threats on social media.
I might not even be able to send my kids
to school depending on how legislation
changes because of the
way I think it just,
it's insane to me how hostile this has
become and it's not doing a service to
research and science move forward and
just the overall dialogues we have in our
culture,
whatever the subject,
what I think is lacking in this debate
or conversation is really compassion from
the provax side or pro mandate side.
I'll say the people who refuse to
acknowledge the vaccine reactions are
happening or that the things
that happened to my daughter,
we're connected because maybe it was
just a coincidence and I just needed
something to pin it on.
You are socially isolated.
You can be isolated by your family,
isolated by the medical community,
community isolated by society as
a whole because they assume you're
unintelligent, uneducated, any rational.
I wish there was just
more compassion that, no,
we don't want to make something difficult.
We just want to be acknowledged.
My daughter was a victim
and she's being punished.
When I signed up for this,
it was a little bit of trepidation coming
into this because you do hear things
in the media.
You know about the people who are anti
vaccine and the way they respond to
physicians and an end. It is a little
bit scary. You know, as as physicians,
we care about people.
There's compassion on,
on the medical community side. We
wouldn't do this if we, if we didn't care.
But again,
you know,
I do have compassion for the families
that have gone through issues with,
you know,
with vaccines and I've,
I have great deal of compassion for
the families that had children die from
preventable diseases.
There shouldn't be any hostility.
There should be discussion. I mean,
we can always question things that,
that's how we evolve. That's how we get
better. If we didn't question anything,
we'd be still in the dark.
Yeah.
Thank you
for sharing your story, doctor. It
was a pleasure. It's a pleasure. Dot.
You've got to kind of say around,
yeah.
Hey guys. I'm Kendra. I'm Aaron
and we're from jubilee media.
Thank you so much for watching
this episode of middle ground.
We try to encourage radical
empathy in our work,
so we're very appreciative that you took
the time to watch one of our videos.
Make sure you let us know what you
think in the comments below. Also,
make sure you're subscribed falls on
Instagram, and we'll see you next time.